the weekend is ready to hit the super
bowl halftime stage under very unique
circumstances
yeah absolutely in a chat with the nfl
network in a press conference yesterday
the singer revealed
the show is so low i didn't think it was
going to be and
don't expect him to be censored
any chance we see a surprise guest pop
up or
fly in or hop on a pirate ship during
the super bowl i've been
reading a lot of rumors i wouldn't bet
on it there wasn't any room
to fit it in the narrative and the story
i was telling in the performance
so yeah there's there's no special
guests no i definitely want to be
respectful to the viewers at home
um i will still incorporate
some of the storyline it's a very
cohesive story i've been telling
throughout this era and throughout this
year so um
the story will continue but definitely
we'll keep it
pg for the families definitely for the
safety
of the players and um
the workers we kind of built the stage
within the stadium
and uh we're also using the field as
well but we wanted to kind of do
something that we've never done before
and um yeah so we built we built the
stage in the stadium but i'm not going
to tell you anything else
because you'd have to watch on sunday
now code code says i don't believe him
he's got something planned
yeah this is the weekend performing by
himself is disappointing
beast's weekend is really a good artist
one of my favorites bean says is he
being deceptive
to keep a secret answer that question
kisha
well he had glasses on and he didn't
have glasses on and the same speech
so he's going through a lot um
how in god's name can you have a 24
minute halftime show which is like is
that even a halftime show is it like a
full-time show what is that it's 24
minutes it's a long time
and you have no special guests i get the
whole idea of having a narrative and
some story it
seems like he's going to do like a mini
movie performance but like if there's
actors couldn't you have
i don't know i feel like with the super
bowl it's such a huge budget experience
that you just expect to see things you
didn't know you needed like you see
collaborations you're like i didn't even
think of this this is
mind-blowing that's what i expected i
expected him to call every friend he had
to act to sing to dance even just walk
by i mean they're all partying in la
anyway so you don't need to follow any
of your kobe protocol you guys were
together last night at the club
which is secretly open so why don't you
guys do that at the super bowl too
that's my right i mean i listen i think
you know
the average show is what 22 minutes
without commercials and he's going over
that
that's a long time to fill i feel like
maybe
again he is going to come out with uh
special guests and special performances
regardless
i think this is going to be very uh
powerful
and something that everyone needs to pay
attention to so he knows he's got this
beautiful platform where everyone's
going to be watching and i think it's
going to be really powerful
murder says he doesn't need any special
guests nelson says he just has a big ego
and he doesn't want any guests there
ashley says i feel like he's pulling i
do agree keisha that this is probably
going to be like a mini movie thing so
it's hard to fit guests in
but i do wonder if he's going with this
narrative that he's been going with over
the past year
is this going to be too weird for
halftime show
viewers like people just want to spec
goal they want to hear the hits they
just want to see some fun
like is this going if he makes the mini
movie where it's a whole thing is it
gonna get
too weird um for me
you know i can make all the jokes about
him as i want but the reality of this is
he's an
incredible visual artist he's an
incredible
artist period so i do expect he's gonna
blow my mind i can't imagine
anybody spending seven million dollars
of their own money just to
smile and look cute uh it ain't gonna
happen right yeah i
i might imagine you know i'm imagining
that he's going to come out of a
helicopter
like it's the sky is the limit there's
not going to be much of an audience he
can literally do anything he could land
i just give me something give me
something that i won't stop talking
about
but i think this year too we need
something
there's no a lot has happened this year
there are a lot of big conversations
that are happening
that platform is beautiful you're
reaching to people in small towns all
across the world
not just america that that he can hit
and
and
and really have those conversations so i
think he's going to use that and
i mean he's going to be jaw-dropping and
whether it's out of a helicopter or
in on a i don't know but but i think
he's going to use the platform
for to to push the conversation for sure
yeah nick says nothing heavy just keep
it fun but you still have messages
within the fun like you think about
what jlo did with the puerto rican flag
on the other side of american flag and
then
her daughter in like the cages so
there's ways to have a message that
doesn't have to be you know super
heavy-handed you can still have fun with
it but yeah it's going to be i think
the weekend's going to be something very
unique it's just going to be interesting
to see
if it works for the halftime show yeah i
just want the weekend i don't want a
weekday
okay it's sunday oh you're waiting for
that line oh
all day all day everyone says it but i
needed to say it i needed to get it off